字幕志愿者 李宗盛
不必
为什么
要是你这样控制面
结果你那天作文灵感来了怎么办
你不用笑了
我等下以后你要是真文被我教到
我跟你讲通常控制页不够
你可能要写到第五页
来我送给你
现在我们很明确
标题号不扣分
听懂了吗
你标题号绝不扣分
什么叫标题号
你拿到的时候请你给我这样写
明明是第一页
可是考卷上第一题应该是作文
对不对
你先写第二题
可是你给我写在哪里
第一页的地方你就给我写这样子
二
对
公文
你就直接的给我写二顿点公文
听懂了吗
我跟你讲不扣分
你第一页
因为我们上面
我们现在有很明确的
非常明确的写
这样标题号
不扣分
听懂了吗
于是接着开始
好了
来现在开始了
这边写什么
來看我
這邊就開始寫了
檔號
我多畫了一個
差掉好了
看得很不順眼
來檔號
然後接著是什麼
保存什麼
年限來紅筆給我拿起來
年限的年字圈起來
我跟妳保證考試的時候妳就宅系啊
考試者我可以看到一堆人寫保存期限
你以為這是牛奶啊?
你以為這公文是牛奶啊?
我告訴你
怎麼記?
我現在告訴你怎麼記?
你看我
請問公文只有保存三天的嗎?
公文隨便都最少幾年
對
公文隨便都一年以上
所以絕對是保存年限
你記起來了沒有?
再說你記起來了沒有?
公文隨便都是一年以上
所以絕對是保存年限
你不要連理由都不知道
很多人是用背的
我現在給你理由
公文隨便都是放一年以上
最爛的那個最不重要的公文也要一年
所以絕對是保存年限
沒有低於以下的啦
我說正常狀況下
好了齁
好了以後再看我
來我告訴你理由
你不要背
為什麼這個要放在最上面
來
檔號要放在最上面的理由是什麼
因為以前不像現在
現在都電腦化對不對
我那個時代還是傳統公文
我們有一個東西叫公文檔案櫃
你們都知道
檔案櫃
所以公文放進去 黨文貴拉開的時候
來我請問你 請你找第3111號公文 你要怎麼找
我說如果黨號有編
我們平常現在不在編 因為我們現在公文量沒大
如果真的黨號有編的話
什麼3111號 你要怎麼找
對 他是不是在上面
你知道理由為什麼在上面了嗎
你公文貴拉開只要幹嘛
你是不是只要這樣翻上面就好
如果這在下面呢 你要一份一份拿起來
你現在知道理由了吧 好氣吧
然後再問你 這個檔案櫃會不會裝滿的一天
會 我再翻到311的時候 先翻到3110的時候
一看上面保存年限的時候
一年 我會幹嘛
我順手就可以把那份
不是丟掉
銷毀
你千萬不要丟掉
不能丟被子啊 你又被打
我們現在正確的用什麼
睡子機啊
多為是吧
所以你先知道理由了嗎?
就這麼簡單
OK了吧?
好,接著
來,我們來誰發公文?
來,我最喜歡教育部
所以教育部發給我的公文喔
教育部發
來,中間就是什麼?
OK,來,就開始寫了
一、二、三、四
來
教育部文別韓
可以嗎
至中
所以我都會算一下格子
空一格至中
教育部函
好了嗎
就是這個地方
來這個地方是發文機關
所以我先給各位
我們先舉個例子
就是教育部發公文給我
懂我意思嗎
就是舉例來講
教育部發公文給我
那什麼內容呢
我最喜歡用
請我幹嘛
去接教育部長一職
你笑這個臉是怎樣?
你是不想混的嗎?
而且我的用語通常不是這樣
我剛剛說教育部請我去 我通常我也不會提
通常教育部要寫貴求
我說好啦 勉為其難
好來 教育部發給我的是不是?來
機關跟誰?
我 我 我 我是
人民 還好你跟我說死老百姓 我打你喔
機關跟我
那我送給各位
因為我在學校
所以原則上是機關對機關的
就是上行的教育部發給大學
沒問題吧
因為大學是在那屬校
所以來
來
教育部含
接著來這個單位是真的還假的
真的所以下面一定要幹嘛
對
地址
地址來
看我
圈圈市
圈圈區
圈圈路
圈圈號
先說OK嗎
來我先暫停
有的同學你現在不要給我緊張
有的同學說
老師我可以這樣寫
圈圈是
然後後面括號線
然後接著圈圈區
圈圈路
圈圈斷
圈圈向
圈圈弄
圈圈號
圈圈樓
可不可以
你看我的眼
你愛怎麼寫就怎麼寫
隨你變OK
他只是要你說
我隨便弄一個地址
你懂我意思嗎?
你懂我在講什麼?
所以有同學你不要緊張到那邊說是
還有旁邊括號
縣市還有什麼區啊什麼不必
有的連零里都寫上去我打爆你了
OK嗎?
接著是誰
聯什麼
聯絡
方式
冒號來
有的會用括號
要不要括號隨你變來沒關係
第一個是什麼?
承辦人,頓號,辦格,然後呢?
電話
頓點
傳真
頓點,然後呢?
E-mail
好了,再括號
先說這裡,OK
OK,來,停
拜託你,不要再問我了
我告訴你答案給你信心
有時候說老師這樣寫可以嗎?
然後有的會問我怎樣
我可不可以寫這樣
聯絡方式
冒號
聯絡人
電話
傳真
Email
一行各一個
你們會看到各式各樣的寫法
懂我的意思嗎
來我告訴你
你愛怎麼寫就怎麼寫你聽懂我在講什麼啊他只是要考你有沒有寫出這個東西你們聽懂我在講什麼嗎所以你要像我這樣括號寫也可以
或者是你寫聯絡方式冒號呢
聯絡人一格 電話一格 傳真一格 email一格
也可以
聽懂了吧
所以我先跟你講
因為我把所有同學遇到的困難都告訴各位
好了齁
好了以後來第二個我在教你怎麼背
看我
我教你怎麼背喔
承辦人後面是先什麼
電話再來咧
再來Email這個次序不能改
你不論是這樣子寫也好還是這樣子寫也好
次序是不能改的
那為什麼我給你理由你就知道你不用背喔
你聽我講一次你就會來你告訴我這三個東西是誰先發明的
電話所以以前是這樣看我
最早是承辦人跟什麼
電話而已
後來越來越進步開始有了什麼
所以才是電話跟什麼
傳真
後來更進步了有了電腦才多出什麼
Email
在這我們會發覺它是按照你發明的資訊下來的
所以看我
如果有一天
真的各位同學我們現在在台灣都用Line嗎
如果有一天那個Line真的綁著人的話
你就會變什麼
電話傳真
電話傳這email叫什麼?
line就寫上去了
你們懂我意思喔?
你們覺得這樣好嗎?
當然不好啊
當然好啊!我講錯了,當然好啊
那有同學現在一定想說,老師,賴怎麼搞?
如果我後面寫QQ你就完了
QQ聽不懂啊?
對啊,那要是改QQ你就完了,我跟你講,你是考哪一國的公務人員?
你搞不清楚啊,你,那個大陸在用的啊?
講個題外話
今天有同學在外面
你知道我現在跟所有考公職的同學
我現在每天都在洗腦
全國只要考公職的我都在給他洗腦
你知道有在洗什麼嗎?
我一定要順便把你們洗腦一下
先問你,你要考什麼?
你要考警察?太好了
講警察
我一年只要交出100個警察
考上100個
我10年就交出幾個?
1000個
我跟你講我已經要走在路上
誰敢攔我
你們知道要講什麼
你看我教鐵路的
剛剛那個鐵路
我每年只要交出100個考上鐵路
10年就有多少個
1000個
我以後做火車搞不好不用付錢
你們不覺得嗎
還有考什麼的
找個男生好了
你要考什麼
你要考鐵路啊
好記住我啊
再換一個女生啊
你要考什麼
你要考警察
記住我啊
我紅燈右轉就幹嘛
包攔下來
斥責一番就好了
不要開我法戰路
所以我現在就給各位洗腦
好啦
所以你看喔
你現在知道這格式了
好 停
我現在講一件事了
你給我聽好
現在我跟妳講一個很真的
來
什麼叫補習
補習的一句話
那個習要給你練習
什麼叫練習
我跟妳講一件事
考試妳不要臨時再給我寫
我跟妳講我不信這一套的
我在考試的時候怎麼寫
來
這一個檔號保存年限
我從這個地方開始喔
我是背下來的
我永遠是第五格
我就是從第五格開始寫
那我先暫停
你試試看
如果你覺得第四格好看的同學
你就從第四格開始寫
如果你覺得第六格好看的同學
你就從第六格開始寫
我跟你講考試你不要憑感覺
從這一個開始寫
我跟你講我不信這檔子是
練習練習再練習
你是從第五格你就從第五格
你是從第四格你就從第四格
我告訴你這個要背
你聽懂了嗎
我跟你講你不要考試值在憑感覺
不相信這個
因為感覺如果那天感覺不好怎麼辦
我送你兩個字叫剉賽
你聽懂我在講什麼了嗎
所以你一定要這樣子寫一次
你在第幾格就第幾格
那唯一不能改的是這一個
然後這一個請跟各位講
這一個住址跟聯絡方式
我們的範圍位置是
中間
偏右
聽懂了嗎
所以
你回去一樣看我
你要從第七格第六格第八格開始寫的同學
你就怎麼給我寫 你看我
你就給我背 1 2 3 4 5 6
我這是第六格 沒寫
你就從第六格開始寫
你聽懂了嗎
知道我要講什麼吧
你不要當場再憑感覺
我跟你講
這個在家裡練習
這個練一次有十分 你要不要
你先聽懂了嗎
好了以後 接著
下面呢
下面我把它換完
先這樣就好了
接著
這一排下面
看好哦
我可以寫什麼
圈圈圈圈圈
這叫什麼
郵地區號
然後接著呢
隨便寫嘛
台北市
圈圈區
圈圈路
圈圈號
這樣就可以了
你要寫區段相弄
靈里隨你變
OK吧
反正考試
接著來看好
什麼東西
受文者
像我的話
他們通常是寄到學校給我
一定是什麼
某某什麼
一定是某某大學
先說到這裡
有沒有問題
那我先讲这个就不用背了啦
因为这个你一定就是从右边往后写
这个还会写错我就打抱你了
来先说这里OK了吗
OK后来下面开始
来请各位看一下
有一个叫发文日期
发文字号
数别密等级解密条件或保密期限
还有另外一个叫附件
你有没有找到
好来我告诉你
你先跟着我一起念
来念哪里
这五个有的同学记不起来
我教你一次
来你看第一个字怎么念
发
数
密
附
有沒有看到
那五個字
就是念最前面那五個字
發發宿密覆
你先跟著我一起念
你念個五次就會了啦
跟我一起來吧
預備
發發宿密覆
被起來了吧
好記吧
你就這樣念成口卷
然後第一個叫什麼
發文什麼
來看一下
發文日期
來現在開始
你給我看清楚喔
怎麼寫
你給我寫哪一個
紅筆給我畫起來
中華民國
你不要給我寫西元喔
你也不要給我寫民國
你更不要什麼都不寫
你聽懂了嗎
我們到現在就是用什麼
中華民國
你不要用一些奇怪的年号
你就用中华民国就对
你不要用一些奇怪
什么西元几年
除非你有本事
你写农历
你敢写的话
最近七月开了
知道吧
难过
我觉得今天
同学特别多还塞满了
你们都没有发现
我乱讲的了
没关系讲个题要让各位高兴下个礼拜一什么节对啊七七情人節啊你不覺得情人節為什麼要放在鬼月嗎?因為情人節講的話都是鬼話吧
意思就告訴你不要信嘛
好,來看一下中華民國,來看一下
某某年,某某月,某某日
好,先說有問題嗎?
好,沒問題,換某有問題了,來看好
有的說老師,為什麼是某某年
現在是三個書寺學某某某年可不可以
你看我的臉
隨你高興
你聽懂了嗎
所以我們這課本是寫圈圈圈
三個也可以
兩個也可以
然後發再來是什麼
發叫什麼
這邊我寫的少了一點
沒關係
大概知道
發文字號
來看一下
圈圈字有看到沒
第
圈號有沒有看到
來
那些圈圈圈
你看有幾個
1 2 3
11個對不對
有找到嗎
來跟各位報告
來這邊
要嘛你就畫四個圈圈
要嘛你就畫三個圈圈
要嘛你就畫11個圈圈
懂我意思啊
那為什麼會是11個圈圈
我先講
原則上我們的發文字號是10個
然後有的地方單位會有字號
所以是最多到11個
懂我意思啊
那我的想法是這樣
請各位看我
這個我沒有要求
可是反正你都畫了
你乾脆就畫11個圈圈會死啊
你聽懂了嗎
你就畫嘛
所以就這樣子啊
圈圈字
第1 2
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
好
OK了嗎
然後好了
好了以後來現在暫停
我這邊有兩種寫法
我都混在一起
我等一下要教各位
接著因為我位置不叫
發文日期發文知道再來
數別
數別空白
那為什麼我先講一下
通常我們的數別那個普通件
我們就空白不寫
東外是好
那有的老師會講你要寫或不寫
我跟各位講我們的公文的那個是
那個行政院的公文格是講的
非常非常非常的明確
我跟你講他非常的明確
普通件
可空白不寫
听懂了吗
我现在非常明确的告诉你
它就是这样子写的
所以你们在考试的时候
你要么你就空白
要么你就写普通件
这个不会被扣分
听懂了吧
你不要为这小地方去担心
我现在就告诉你
学生担心你就糟了
你不用担心
要么你就空白
要么你就写普通件
OK了
好 再来
我就讲了
來最難的最難背的就是這個
數別及什麼
解密條件或保存保密
保密什麼紅筆拿起來
期限
這就是期限了為什麼
因為我送給各位期的意思就是
我們的公文有一種狀況
我就知道
你就會知道為什麼不寫保存保密年限
送給各位
我們公文有一種最快的事
例如文道即解密
我們有這個狀況
什麼意思
就是這一邊是密件
你們都不能看
我是發給他的
可是聞到他看完後
這個東西就可以解密了
你懂我意思喔
這聞到才十分鐘吧
所以你知道用奇異的意思了吧
因為他還包含了短時間
各位聽懂了嗎
懂我意思喔
那我先講
這個後面你就空白
你不要亂編喔
我們這個保密的方法
或解密方法有一定喔
你們不要亂寫
你就空白
OK了吧
你不要亂寫喔
說什麼啊什麼
說到公文後刻三個想投自動解密
我打爆你也沒有這種解法的
你不要亂編
好了,以後來發發宿密
再來什麼?
復件
然後這個復件它下面寫個儒文
為什麼儒文?是因為這個文章中
你看它的說明第三點
簡訟公文程式條例
第某某條某某條某某條修正案
有沒有?然後後面寫各三份
有沒有找到?
有找到嗎?
然後這是因為它的復件
所以它寫儒文可以
懂我意思嗎?
請問一下先說這裡有問題嗎
你們都沒有發覺有問題喔
換我講
其實我這邊是故意寫
其實這兩個是不對的
可是我等一下再告訴你
我是故意這樣寫的
來
你們先看一下
你們有沒有發覺
這個發文字號的地方
前面是圈圈字
地圈圈圈號的地方有沒有找到
你注意那個圈圈是不是不太一樣
有沒有發現到
有的同學可能沒注意到
來我講一下看一下
你看一下你們的發文字號
他是不是寫這樣子
圈圈字
D
會發現他圈圈畫的樣子不太一樣
來我先跟各位講
現在
不扣分
也不會影響
懂得是吧
那有的同學很仔細的
我現在就告訴你為什麼了
來
通常我們在寫的時候
如果是
字就是某某地區的話或是某某文字的話是用這一種
這個是文字用的圈圈
正圓形
如果是數字的圈圈通常是畫什麼
橢圓形的圈圈
數字用
通常是橢圓形
文字用
通常是正圓形
在座聽懂了嗎
然後我先講現在沒有印性規定了
聽懂了吧
所以你要分不分其實都這樣
看我的手勢
都OK
你先聽懂了吧
可是如果你真的要講究同學你就去分吧
所以我舉例來講你看我
你先不要看答案
你看我
來這個是郵遞區號
來是正園還是橢園
對橢園
然後來某某市
要用正園還是橢園
對某某市某某區
這就是正圓
懂我意思嗎
所以有可能發生什麼樣
以前的考題就
某某是某某區
某某段後面開始的幾號有沒有
就改成橢圓了
因為那是數字
你們現在懂我意思嗎
所以原則上現在不會考你
不會影響了
懂我意思嗎
好 第二個
來
你們覺得畫這圈圈累不累
很累對不對
所以預告一下
前
已經不只前年了
大前年已經規定了
以前考試可以帶一種詞
那个尺我们以前叫做公文圈圈尺
你们大概没听过吧
就是那个尺上面有各式各样的圆圈
你在考试尺可以放那个圆圈在上面画
好圆好漂亮
现在一律当作弊
所以你不要给我带那个公文圈圈尺进去画
知道讲什么吧
因为已经废纸了
所以你不要没事拿一个圈圈
哇那以前那个圈圈画起来好漂亮好圆哦
因为它就是圆的
现在不行了OK吗
好了
好了以后还没有完
来
來
這個先放著
我等一下會談
好接著
開始了
到中間
我畫大一點
因為這邊就簡單多了
好這樣就夠了
我再畫這樣就好
好這樣這些就夠好第一個是什麼好,竹子,来,请各位看竹子冒号好了,来,我先讲
我看我们后面没写
我确定一下
OK,好,没关系
来,没有写,我告诉各位,请看我
竹子前不灌数字
聽懂了嗎
我全部背給你聽
你聽我講一次就好
阻止前面
每一個斷名前面
不加數字
所以沒有這樣子
一阻止
二說明
三辦法
沒有
直接就是阻止
所以阻止前面
不加數字
不加斷名
斷名前面不加數字
先說OK了嗎
第二個
聽好
來
阻止裡面不分項
直接說明
什麼叫不分項
來看我
沒有阻止一什麼二什麼三什麼沒有
直接寫阻止沒有分一二三的
聽懂了嗎
怎麼寫來
緊接冒號之右開始書寫
就這樣子
例如阻止怎麼寫
剛剛講的教育部發給我什麼
貴求陳怡老師
訴接教育部長一職
可以吧
不行也可以換別啊
貴旗有什麼敵人啊
是書結中華民國總統一職也可以啊
欸不要不要不要不要
我不要不要不要
我不要亂講話
佩佩佩佩佩佩佩佩
我不想被抓去關
先說OK了齁
好OK哦
等一下
來
這一個地方你要給我對齊
我現在什麼都沒有教你
你先格式給我寫
要不要對齊
齁
對齊後呢
接著後面寫期望語
什麼叫期望語?我寫一個東西給各位例如這個
對下行文的叫請
請
查照
就是叫下面人啊
你看了以後有沒有照辦
查閱後照辦
聽懂了嗎?就叫下面人請查照先說這叫期望語聽懂了嗎?
給各位一個名稱先看我
因為這個名稱就寫在這裡請查照
那這個我們有一個正確的名字
我們叫齊旺宇
我們在公文上有一個正確的名稱
什麼叫齊旺宇就是
我對你的期望是什麼
你聽懂了嗎
所以我舉例來講
我舉例來講
例如我現在是警政署署長
因為我知道他要考警察
結果他現在當上了局長
我還是比他大吧
所以他有事情
例如說他今天抓到了什麼
什麼玫瑰花學運的學生
我隨便亂講你不要害我
玫瑰花學音可以吧
隨便
他抓到後問我要怎麼處理
有沒有錯
他對我的期望有可能是什麼
請和視
聽懂了嗎
就是期望語
通常就放在你主子說完後
放在這個地方的
叫做期望語
聽懂了齁
好問題就來了
請各位請禁
來看我
你們都沒問題
換我跟各位講了
期望語
現在我們的期望語是固定的
只能用這些固定的期望
聽懂了嗎
古代你愛怎麼寫
就怎麼寫
所以你不要拿古代跟我
例如我告訴他怎麼做
我叫他請查照
因為我是整官他是我屬下
沒錯吧
可是在古代我可以寫什麼
我期望你照辦就對了
有問題嗎
你聽懂嗎
而且我口氣更狠
你懷疑啊
那是我對你的期望
你們聽懂了嗎?
所以我先講
我們的公文在古代有個大概的樣子
只是說那些期望語啊
千奇百怪
所以後來中華民國政府
全部統一
就是用這些字眼
不然的話你知道期望語有的寫起來就很難聽了
你懷疑啊
或是怎麼樣
直接罵髒話的都有啊
罵髒話 你有疑問嗎?
我先跟各位講
但我不方便跟你們提
我就曾經在聖旨上看到類似這種的文章
狂帝罵得很難聽啊
你照做就是啊
你有疑問嗎
你們聽懂啊
那暑假收到已經嚇得什麼
半死
知道了齁
齊旺宇先說這位置OK了嗎
所以如果是我的話就會怎樣
請什麼那個陳毅老師啊
宿介就義務部長一職
齊旺宇他可以寫什麼
會求啊
不行
請查照
他就要我去做
請我查明後來照辦
查明後就代表這就是真的還假的
查明後照辦
來我送給你喔
你給我記一個翻譯
很多人用背的
我跟你講你公文用背就完了
這個照就是什麼意思
照什麼
照辦
所以請各位暫停
你覺得請查到是可以用給長官的還是用在屬下
你去翻譯這個字照辦是什麼意思
是發給長官還是發給屬下
對你會了
你還要背嗎?你懂這一支,一定是發給屬下的嘛
好,這是期望雨的位置,先說O不OK
期望雨我們到時候會整理給各位
好了,以後我還沒有完,我再問你
來,期望雨前面是逗號還句號
一堆同學問我,來我現在告訴你不用擔心
我沒有寫完
句號、逗號都可以
所以你知道,因為學生要考試他會注意到非常小的細節
我今天通通給各位
期望與前面你要逗號句號都可以
我解釋給你聽
逗號的意思就是我的話只是暫停
我接著講警察照
句號的意思是我的話講完了
講完了
請您照辦
接著講第二句
所以前面這個逗號句號都可以
OK了嗎
你不要為小季節在害怕
好了以後
主旨接著說什麼
說明
好,來,說明
請聽好
冒號,請看我
如果不分項次
就是沒有說明一,說明二,說明三
就是不分條項的話,聽懂了嗎?
這叫不分條項的話
緊接冒號之右書寫
就跟上面一樣,就從這地方開始
就從這邊接著開始寫
聽懂了嗎?
聽懂了,好了,以後停
如果你回去看到書上這樣寫
來,阻止了
緊接冒號之下書寫
然後他說說明不分相次
緊接冒號之右書寫
我跟你講
結果同學讀到這麼仔細
冒號之下跟冒號之右是一樣的
你不要為了字眼嚇到
你現在懂我意思吧
先說這個有沒有問題
沒問題
接著
如果分相次的話
怎麼樣
來
另列
縮格
書寫
什麼叫另列縮格?你聽好喔
另列就是有說明一說明二
另列什麼叫另列?
是另外一列
縮格是什麼意思?
我就問你,縮格是什麼意思?
對,往後縮一格的意思